[Music]  i just got off the stage with drew  barrymore please welcome for the first  time ever in the actual studio live and  in person it's emmye 10.  it was so fun just to like meet her in  person for the first time  and i just can't wait to be on it again  and again  this is my first time in new york city  and i'm learning so much already  for instance  did you know that the yellow and black  taxis used to be red and green  i sure didn't another fun fact the  oldest building in new york was built in  1642 which is a very long time ago  and did you know that about 800  different languages  are spoken here  like hola banjo ciao and more  i love the food here and all of the  giant buildings but as far as memories  go coming to the drew barrymore show is  the top  make sure you check out me on the drew  barrymore show and at 7 questions with  me bye